حسن بالاستناد لا تصريحات سابقه لوزير لي
الرئيس اردوغان اضافه الى خلوصيا افكار
فان تركيا
على الاقل في فتره الاخيره عن ثلاث نقاط
بعينها دون عن سواها نتحدث عن مدينه تل
رفعت اضافه الى مدينه عين العرب كوباني
وكذلك الامر مدينه منبج لابد من تسليط
الضوء على توزع هذه النقاط مدينه الرفعت
وان كانت صغيره من مقارنه مع باقي
المدينتين ولكنها موجوده في منطقه غير
متصله بباقي المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
وحدات حمايه الشعب الكرديه ما يعرف به
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه متصله تماما مع
مناطق سيطره النظام جنوبا مع حلبها محاطه
بمناطق سيطره المعارضه اضافه الى عين
العرب عين العرب كذلك الامر تقع في منطقه
متصله مع باقي مناطق وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه ولكنها في منطقه بين مناطق سيطره
المعارضه يبدو ان القوات التركيه او
الرئيس الدهان يختاره هذه النقاط بعينها
ليصلها ما يقول انها مناطق سيطره معارضه
من جهه وايضا يحول دون اتصال مناطق سيطرت
هذه القوات والذي دائما ما يصفها بانهق
قوات ارهابيه تسعى لانشائي ممر على طول
الحدود التركيه يهدد امن واستقرار البلاد
ايضا الاهميه الرمزيه لعين العرب ربما
بالنسبه للمقاتلين من وحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه ربما هذا ما يصاحب المهمه كذلك
الامر لابد من التفكير بما التاليه الحرب
الاخيره في عام 2019 على العمليه العسكريه
الاخيره انتهت بتعهدات الامريكيه والروسيه
ان تنسحب هذه الوحدات من الشريط الحدود مع
تركيا بمسافه 30 كلم الى العمق وهذا الامر
الذي لم يتحقق حتى بعد مرور اكثر من سنتين
ونصف على هذه العمليه وهذا الان ما تطالب
به تركيا جدد مطالبه تركيا
صاحبي هذه القوات مره اخرى والزام الاطراف
الضامنه
بعودها لتركيا كذلك الامر التهديدات
الاخيره او الهجوم الاخير الذي تعرضت له
تركيا هو الذي عاد الحديث عن هذه مثل هذه
العمليه مره اخرى همم الى الاوساط هنا في
تركيا على صعيد التحركات العسكريه كان
هناك
قبل يومين تحرك باتجاه مدينه كليسره
العسكري همم تركي حسن اضافه الى الزيارات
غير المبرمجه على جدول تحركات الوزير
خلوصي افكار سواء زيارته لي مقر قياده
الاركان البريه في همم انقره او الى مقر
قياده عمليات المخلب القفل هذه العمليات
العسكريه التي نفذ في سوريا وشمال العراق
على حد سواء وتستهدف في تركيا ما تقول
انها تنظيمات ارهابيه تصريحات المتكرره
دائما الرئيس اردوغان عن اقتراب هذه
العمليه او انها وشيكه هو الذي يرفع
الحديث مره اخرى عنها ولكن على الاقل
المؤشرات هنا في الارض لا تشير الى مثل
هذا التحرك حتى الان